[Applause]
let's talk about taiwan
and the taiwan strait
because right now these waters aren't
exactly calm u.s ships have been
transiting the strait monthly angering
beijing china sending nearly 150
warplanes into taiwan's air defense zone
forcing taiwan's fighter jets to
scramble with taiwan caught in a kind of
tug of war between the u.s and china
there are genuine fears about where this
could all end up the only way that the
us and china would go to war would be
over taiwan so why is taiwan such a
flashpoint between two of the world's
biggest powers
why is the island not officially
considered a country
and what do microchips have to do with
it all
[Music]
taiwan is an island stuck in a kind of
political limbo it's a democratic
self-governing territory just over the
water is china which claims taiwan as
its own but many taiwanese take issue
with that then you add in the u.s which
has taken on the role of neighborhood
cop and you end up with taiwan as the
focus for many big competing interests
but to understand how we got here you
have to know the back story
taiwan was ruled by imperial china for
200 years then japan had it for 50 years
after winning a war against china but
when japan lost in world war ii china
one of the victors got taiwan back again
then you had the chinese civil war mao
zedong's communist forces took over the
mainland while the other side the
nationalist forces of chiang kai-shek
escaped to taiwan
so in 1949 china sort of split in two
and you had two rival governments one in
taiwan one in beijing both claiming they
were the true government of china the
site in taiwan was known as the republic
of china the roc and that's still the
island's official name today and on the
mainland the communist party declared a
brand new chinese state the people's
republic of china prc for short now
remember the u.s wasn't exactly a fan of
communism
and so it was the roc in taiwan that
mostly got the international recognition
including a seat at the u.n
but by the 1970s that seat didn't really
make sense anymore
the un passed a resolution confirming
the representatives from the prc as the
only lawful representatives of china to
the united nations
and so the roc was out we have been
deserted
we have been forsaken so what does all
this mean for taiwan's political status
today well it leaves it in that limbo we
talked about at the beginning now from
beijing's perspective it's pretty clear
china is one country and taiwan is part
of it
right now the island governs itself but
beijing's position is that eventually
it'll be reunited with the mainland
and lately chinese president xi jinping
has been emphasizing that a lot and
linking it to his big policy known as
national rejuvenation
so what about taiwan's status according
to taiwan well the president saying gwen
and her party have never fully accepted
the idea that taiwan is a part of china
but at the same time they're not
explicitly pushing for taiwan to be
recognized as independent
it is a bit of a fudge really they say
that taiwan is effectively independent
so they just want things to stay the way
they are woman
okay so what about the us well their
position is also a bit of a fudge it
even has an official name strategic
ambiguity on the one hand they do
acknowledge that taiwan is a part of
china and not an independent country
there's no official u.s embassy in
taipei for example but on the other hand
they sort of want china to leave taiwan
alone and the u.s has suggested they
would defend taiwan militarily in
certain circumstances there are reports
that the united states has made clear to
china that it would defend taiwan
if chinese attack is unprovoked
and
on the flip side that it's made clear to
taiwan that it will not come to taiwan's
aid
if the chinese attack is provoked so
that's the big picture if things spin
out of control we could potentially be
talking about a war between the us and
china
it means that when things are tense
around taiwan it's a big deal and things
have been getting tense
[Music]
under president donald trump the u.s got
a lot cozier with taiwan than previous
presidents and biden's administration
has effectively continued in the same
direction
over in taiwan the political climate
shifted in 2016 when president xienguin
took over from a pro-beijing president
she's been pretty outspoken against
beijing and the question of taiwan's
status has taken on new significance
after people in taiwan saw what china
did in hong kong
the people of taiwan so what they
treated hong kong we just realized that
their promises it's not something we can
trust hong kong has been completely
absorbed into china the last remaining
piece that is missing is taiwan then you
add the fact that both taiwan and china
are expanding their military so when we
see headlines about china flying 150
warplanes near taiwan and the u.s
according to this wall street journal
report secretly deploying troops there
well it's no small thing the potential
for war does exist
i do not think it is very high but i do
believe it is growing and there are a
few other factors that raise the stakes
even higher when we're talking about
taiwan
first up its location it sits in what's
called the first island chain in the
western pacific that extends to japan in
the north all the way down to indonesia
in the south going through the
philippines and so if
china were to take over taiwan and
deploy pla forces
on taiwan that would truly pose an
existential threat to japan and japan of
course is a very important ally of the
united states then there are those
microchips we mentioned earlier
taiwan is a world leader when it comes
to semiconductor technology the tiny
chips that the world has come to rely on
they're in everything from smartphones
to aircraft
as far as the smallest most advanced
ships go around 90 percent of them are
made in taiwan this actually is a
capability that china is aspiring to and
so then there's this very important
question of what would happen
um
if china controlled that production the
other big thing about taiwan is that it
acts as a kind of lightning rod for the
big political rivalry between the us and
china and how they see themselves and
each other for the chinese perspective
it just seems like king of the mountain
the us uh is the most powerful economic
military and political uh country in the
world and they want to stay that way
taiwan is now
a mature and vibrant democracy
and the united states has a
long-standing commitment um
to protecting and advancing democracy
let's not forget about the 24 million
people who live there
a recent poll suggests around 10 of
taiwanese say they want unification with
china at some point
34 say they want independence at some
point
but a majority 51 percent say they
simply want to keep things the way they
are forever most people believe that the
best scenario for taiwan
for the
the short run at least is just kicking
the can down the road helping taiwan to
preserve its freedoms continue to have
economic prosperity having
a limited voice in the international
community
but being able uh to
essentially be an autonomous entity
things with taiwan might be ambiguous
but maybe it's better that way maybe
taiwan is an example where doing nothing
is actually the best option
if you found that useful and want to
know more about what's going on in the
region watch our episode on the south
china sea see you next week
[Music]